Does this sound familiar?
You're all excited to start knitting a
sweater, and bam, you've hit a roadblock.
Maybe the fit wasn't right,
the yarn didn't cooperate,
or you realized too late that you
were missing some key skills.
Knitting a Sweater isn't just about
casting on, it's about
planning for success.
And today, I'll show you how to do that.
Hi, and welcome back to Knit It Now.
In our last video,
we talked about why knitting a Sweater
on a Knitting Machine isn't instant magic.
It takes planning, skills, and practice.
Today, we're diving into the first
and most important step,
planning your sweater design and making
sure you have the skills
to bring it to life.
Think of it like building a house.
You wouldn't start building
without blueprints, right?
The same goes for sweaters.
A little planning now
saves frustration later.
That means choosing the right pattern,
evaluating your yarn,
and making sure your design works
for you and your knitting machine.
First, decide on your sweater style.
Ask yourself,
do you want a pullover or a cardigan?
Are you looking for a relaxed
fit or something more tailored?
What sleeve style and sleeve
length do you like?
Now be honest.
What's your skill level?
If you're new to machine knitting,
I recommend starting with a simple
Drop Shoulder Sweater.
It's beginner friendly and it lets you
focus on the basics without a whole
bunch of shaping or fuss and fuss.
For a great beginner friendly sweater
project, check out our course
called Your Second sweater.
Here's a quick preview of what's included.
And Remember, with Knit It Now patterns,
you can use any yarn,
any machine, and your own gage.
No need to match a pattern's gage.
About yarn.
Not all yarns work well
with every knitting machine.
Make sure your yarn matches your machine's
gage range and always, always swatch.
Swatching helps you see how the yarn
behaves and ensures accurate
pattern calculations.
A sweater It is investment in your time,
so start with the right foundation.
Now, let's take a look
at a pattern and break it down.
Casting on.
Do you know how to create
a stable cast on for sweaters?
What about hems or ribbing or
that dreaded stockinette curl?
Shaping.
Are you comfortable with neat
and tidy increases and decreases?
Can you work short rows?
Finishing.
Do you know to neatly join seams
and add neck lines or hems?
Now, if any of these sound
intimidating, don't worry.
You can always practice on a smaller
project and check out the Knit It Now
tutorial library in our
Skill Builders series.
Members also have access to our entire
Custom Patty Library,
giving you the flexibility to create
sweaters that fit you, your gage,
your machine, and your style.
The key The key is to match your sweater
design with your current skills or ones
you're willing to learn and practice.
Challenge yourself, but don't
set yourself up for frustration.
Start small, build confidence,
and then tackle more advanced designs.
What sweater design are
you thinking about making?
Let me know in the comments.
Are you ready to plan
your perfect sweater?
I've put together a free planning
checklist to help you get started.
Download it using that link below.
And if you need extra help, Knit It Now
has step-by-step resources to guide you.
In our next video, we'll bust some common
myths and mistakes that can
derail your project.
We'll see you soon and happy knitting.